so nächster tagesordnungspunkt
an diesem letzten sitzungstag vor der
weihnachtspause die ampel fraktionen
wollen den corona hilfsfonds und ein
halbes jahr verlängern da gibt es einen
gesetzentwurf der vorliegt und der heute
auch abgestimmt wird die
unternehmenshilfen sollen fortgesetzt
werden bis zum 30 juni 2022 die ampel
fraktionen plan allerdings den umfang
der möglichen hilfen für die unternehmen
zu kürzen bisher konnte dieser fonds
garantien von insgesamt 400 milliarden
euro gewähren und klamme unternehmen zu
helfen
dieser umfang soll jetzt auf insgesamt
100 milliarden euro verringert werden
und den auftakt der debatte macht
reinhard houben für die fdp-fraktion der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
von 3,6 auf 3,5 von 5,1 prozent auf 4,0
prozent
von 5,1 prozent auf 3,7 prozent das sind
die in den vergangenen tagen
vorgestellten anpassungen der
konjunkturprognosen der bekannten
deutschen
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute für das
beach des kommenden jahres wir sind
angesichts dieser zahlen offensichtlich
in der situation dass wir noch nicht von
einer vollständigen stabilisierung
unserer wirtschaft in deutschland
sprechen könnten deswegen verlängern wir
heute den wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds wir brauchen ihn
wir schaffen damit kontinuität in einer
immer noch schwierigen lage aber diese
verlängerung erfolgt mit augenmaß daher
bleiben die 100 milliarden euro für die
kfw corona sonderprogramme unberührt wir
reduzieren jedoch das volumen für
garantien des bundes zur absicherung von
krediten von 400 auf 100 milliarden euro
und der umfang der möglichen
rekapitalisierungen siegen von 100
milliarden
auf 50 milliarden euro angesichts der
bisher abgerufene mittel in höhe von
acht milliarden euro gerade in dieser
dritten säule des wsf bleiben wir
insgesamt im wsf handlungsfähig aber
über führen ihn in die finanzpolitischen
realitäten
am wichtigsten ist jedoch mit der
befristung des zeitraums machen wir klar
dass diese hilfen nicht bis zum sankt
nimmerleins tag laufen werden damit
behalten wir das ziel des wsf im blick
die leistung substanzieller hilfen nach
eingehender prüfung in akuten notlagen
der wsf quasi als ultima ratio sprich
sobald sich ein unternehmen wieder
konsolidiert hat zahlt es die kredite
und einlagen zurück und konkurriert
wieder auf dem freien markt das ist uns
wichtig wir glauben an den markt und an
den wettbewerb wir glauben nicht an
starts wirtschaftlichen dirigismus
nach jeder hilfestellung muss er sich
auch wieder
zeitnah also der bsf aus dem betroffenen
unter dem zurückziehen das ziel
erreichen wir so hatte die lufthansa in
der größten krise der luftfahrt mit der
bundesregierung und der eu-kommission im
sommer 2020 einen 9 milliarden euro
schweres rettungspaket ausgehandelt 3
milliarden kamen von der kfw 6 vom dsf
in diesem rahmen erwarb der bund auch 20
prozent an der lufthansa damit konnte
die lufthansa stabilisiert und eine
sechsstellige anzahl von arbeitsplätzen
gesichert werden
im februar diesen jahres begannen die
lufthansa einen teil der in anspruch
genommenen kredite zurückzuzahlen und
mitte november hatte sie sämtliche
kredite insgesamt 3,5 milliarden
zurückgezahlt der bund hat schon im
august einen teil seiner lufthansa
aktien abgestoßen und ist noch mit 14
prozent an diesem konzern beteiligt hier
wird der bund bis oktober 20 23 alle
seine verbliebenen anteile verkaufen
genauso war der wsf gedacht dass sich
unternehmen die darauf verzichten können
auch wieder die hilfen zurückgeben und
es liegt auch im interesse der
unternehmen lufthansa chef carsten spohr
sprach zuletzt bezogen auf die tilgung
der kredite von einem mentalen
befreiungsschlag für sein unternehmen
dadurch scheidet der staat letztendlich
als aktionär auch aus die vorliegende
verlängerung des wsf steht dabei in
einer linie mit der beschlossenen
verlängerung der überbrückungshilfen und
der neustadt hilfe damit senden wir ein
klares signal an die vielen von der
krise betroffenen unternehmen
selbstständigen und beschäftigten wir
lassen sie in der krise nicht allein der
bund ist da werden unter dem in
unverschuldeten notlagen geraten meine
damen und herren
erlauben sie mir aber noch eine
bemerkung zu der debatte des forfour
gehenden
tagesordnungspunktes helge braun hat
davon gesprochen
die ampel würde die axt an die
schuldenbremse ansetzen allein allein an
dem handeln jetzt beim wsf können sie
erkennen wenn öffentliche gelder nicht
gebraucht werden sind wir als ampel auch
in der lage auf gelder zu verzichten
vielen dank
der umfang der möglichen hilfen wird
etwas gekürzt wird erheblich gekürzt
muss man sagen aber dem hilfen werden
verlängert der bsf also der wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds diese abkürzung
werden sie in diese debatte natürlich
noch häufig hören war eingeführt worden
mit der korona krise um notleidende
unternehmen zu retten die lufthansa ist
schon genannt worden frau präsidentin
sehr geehrter apa diese maske redet hier
um sehr geehrter herr minister habe ich
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
bevor ich zur wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds komme er habe
möchte ich ihnen zur ernennung zumindest
dafür wirtschaft und klimaschutz ganz
herzlich gratulieren ich habe gehört sie
haben ein gut das haus übernommen oder
übertragen bekommen und wie sich in
einer demokratie gehört ist glaube ich
der übergang sehr professionell
vonstatten gegangen das erste gesetz
dass sie in ihrer neuen verantwortung
und einbringen das ist die fortführung
die fortführung des wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds den ihr vorgänger
peter altmaier bereits initiiert hat und
sie haben ein paar anpassungen
vorgenommen die zumindest für nicht
schlüssig sind und wollen nun den
maximalbetrag wird daran team von
vormals 400 milliarden euro auf 100
milliarden euro festlegen ich glaube das
kann man machen wird es ist in dieser
phase jetzt verantwortbar und dass sie
dieses instrument fortführen das ist
eine gute nachricht insbesondere eine
gute nachricht für die unternehmen aber
infolge dessen natürlich auch für die
arbeitnehmer die das dürfen wir einfach
mal sagen beide in dieser partie nie
pandemie vielfach über sich hinaus
gewachsen sind und zwar seinerzeit bei
der konstruktion des wsf wichtig dass
wir ein signal senden ein signal senden
dass man sich auf den staat verlassen
kann denn den unternehmen die durch die
korona maßnahmen
unverschuldet in schwierigkeiten geraten
sind die musste geholfen werden alles
andere wäre verantwortungslos gewesen
und deshalb werden wir heute diesen wsf
selbstverständlich zustimmen und sehr
geehrter herr minister das sollten wir
vielleicht auch nicht vergessen dass wir
eben diesen finanziellen kraftakt auch
nur stemmen können weil wir in den
vergangenen jahren vielleicht nicht
alles aber doch sehr sehr vieles richtig
gemacht haben und sie herr hat sie sind
nun für mich zumindest der sechste
wirtschaftsminister den ich als
haushälter begleite ich freue mich auf
die anstehenden haushaltsberatungen mit
ihnen und ich kann ihnen versprechen wir
werden viel in den kommenden wochen
kommenden monaten miteinander zu tun
haben und dabei das darf man vielleicht
auch mal sagen fand ich es toll dass sie
bei ihrer antrittsrede ministerium
gesagt haben dass das bessere argument
gewinnen soll und ich glaube sie haben
dann gesagt nur geschlagen von dem noch
besseren und ich kann ihnen das
versichert sie werden aus reihen der
unions fraktion auch von mir ganz
persönlich nur noch bessere argumente
hören die sie hoffentlich aber auch
umsetzen
[Applaus]
ein
wenig verwundert herr minister
allerdings dass ihre dann anscheinend
zweiter amtshandlung erst einmal die
schaffung von 28 neuen
hochdotierten personalstellen
hauptsächlich für das amt des vize
kanzlers war da haben sie sich fast ein
ministerium im ministerium geschaffen
das muss man erst mal bringen sie
befinden sich aber hier das darf für den
us-einsatz guter tradition mit einem
ihrer amtsvorgänger mit sigmar gabriel
der auch sofort nach dem amtsantritt die
vizekanzler stelle auch mit stellen so
ausgerufen hat aber ganz ehrlich der war
bescheiden hat sie das muss man sich
unter sigmar gabriel erst mal vorstellen
aber so ich wollte es fast mal sagen so
opulent hat der das nicht gemacht und
das soll schon was heißen übrigens
wurden das können wir dieser stelle auch
mal sagen diese stellen wie im
ministerium zurückgefahren sodass sie
eigentlich nun im wirtschaftsministerium
rein rechnerisch zwei vizekanzler
abteilung haben das ist schon großartig
finde ich darf das in dieser stelle
deshalb auch sagen mir macht der stellen
aufwuchs auch schon bei der vorherigen
regierung große sorge und weil das immer
wieder gesagt wird otto ich habe das
auch schon bei der vorherigen regierung
gefordert dass für haushälter vielleicht
eine jährliche einprozentige
stelleneinsparungen wieder ausweisen
müssen deshalb seinerzeit lieber otto
gaza großem applaus bei euch heute ist
das anscheinend anders
deshalb auch herr beck ich würde mich
freuen wenn sie neben dem sicherlich
auch in der union umstritten den
notwendigen thema klima nicht vergessen
dass die industrie dass das handwerk
dass der handel dass der tourismus der
gesamte im mittelstand das brot und
butter geschäft ihres hauses ist bitte
lassen sie bei allen dingen wo sie auf
klimaschutz schauen lassen sie diese
wichtigen bereiche nicht verkümmern
legen sie den unternehmen nicht fesseln
an entfesseln sie diese mit
ideenreichtum dann wissen sie die union
da müssen sie mich als ihr einen
haushältern hop berichterstatter an
ihrer seite in diesem sinne herzlichen
dank
andreas mattfeldt war das für die cdu
csu fraktion und im haushaltsausschuss
sind verschiedene abgeordnete für
verschiedene wirtschaftspläne zuständig
das wird dann besonders interessant wenn
hier haushaltswoche im bundestag ist für
den nächsten haushalt 2022 jetzt eine
erste rede wieder hier die angekündigt
wird und diesmal ist es eine abgeordnete
der spd das ist verena hubers die gleich
neue stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd geworden
ist
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich war selbst unternehmerin und ich
weiß wie schwer es ist dran zu bleiben
auch in schwierigen zeiten wie es auch
ist wenn man meine nacht nicht schlafen
kann oder mehrere wenn man sich überlegt
wie man gehälter und auch rechnungen
zahlt natürlich plant man langfristig
mit business planungen mit ganz schön
excel-tabellen aber manche dinge die
kann man eben nicht planen dazu gehört
eine krise und erst recht eine pandemie
und dieses virus das hat erstmals den
stopp knopf uns alle gedrückt die
familien die kinder das gesundheitswesen
aber natürlich auch die wirtschaft
natürlich auch unsere unternehmen wir
sind auf einmal alle zu hause geblieben
wir wollten solidarisch sein aber die
reiseindustrie der einzelhandel die
gastronomie die hotellerie um nun mal
ganz paar hier zu nennen die haben es
natürlich mit aller wucht gespürt und
deswegen war es auch richtig dass wir
als politik geholfen haben flexibel
pragmatisch und auch solidarisch
das waren die überbrückungshilfen das
war das kurzarbeitergeld aber in der
krise da muss man auch mal neue wege
gehen und nicht an morgen denken sondern
direkt an übermorgen denn da müssen wir
auch noch mal rauskommen und der
wirtschaft stabilisierungsfonds ist
genauso ein langfristiges vehikel ein
instrument mit mut an statt mit
gießkanne wir haben nämlich ein
zielgenaues hilfs konstrukten es gibt ja
auch unternehmen die können nicht zur
sparkasse um die ecke gehen und es ist
geklärt es gibt unternehmen die haben
nicht von den corona hilfen den vielen
die haben da nicht reingepasst und der
wirtschaft stabilisierungsfonds das ist
ein baukasten und da ist jede menge drin
unter anderem kredite bürgschaften aber
auch die stille beteiligung
und in der krise da sehen wir als staat
primär die chance und nicht nur die
sanierungsfälle und das ist nämlich
genau richtig
[Applaus]
und das instrument der stillen
beteiligung will ich hier nochmal ganz
besonders erläutern wissen
eigenkapitalfinanzierungen wir als staat
wir gehen hin und wir übernehmen
unternehmensanteile das bedeutet wenn es
dann wieder bergauf geht dann
partizipieren wir auch an dem erfolg und
das war auch eine leere wenn man mal den
blick über den atlantik wirft die
obama-regierung die hat das sehr
erfolgreich auch praktiziert in der
einen oder anderen krise und einiges
diese erkenntnisse sind auch beim
aufsetzen in dieses programm mit
eingeflossen und es ist doch der staat
wie wir uns vorstellen als
gemeinwohlorientierter ankerinvestor
unserer sozialen marktwirtschaft und das
auch in krisenzeiten
und dass lufthansa beispiel was wir eben
auch schon gehört haben zeigt doch dass
es geklappt hat wir haben die jobs
gerettet wir haben aber auch dafür
gesorgt dass wir aus dieser pandemie mit
der pandemie herauskommen können dass
wir an den gewinnen langfristig
partizipieren und ich nenne es mal so
das eine ist eine wirtschaftliche
rendite und das andere ist die soziale
rendite und die es mir besonders wichtig
als sozialdemokratinnen und
deswegen bitte ich sie dass wir gleich
zu stimmen dieses instrument zu
verlängern bis nächstes jahr 2022 zum 30
juni wir wollen und das ist auch möglich
im rahmen der von der eu kommission
gesetzten rahmenbedingungen
wir wollen das volumen noch einmal
anpassen weil wir wie richtig gesagt
nicht den vollen umfang benötigen wir
gehen runter auf 150 milliarden
und zum abschluss möchte ich noch mal
hier ein appell an alle richten
natürlich sind wir an der pandemie
natürlich sind wir in der krise wir
kommen da nur miteinander aus deswegen
lassen sie sich impfen impfen impfen
werden sie in ihrem umfeld das ist der
einzige weg raus und das zweite mann
kann auch noch einen persönlichen
beitrag zu dieser ökonomischen krise
leisten ich weiß nicht ob sie alles
schon ihre geschenke haben für den
weihnachtsbaum oder andere
feierlichkeiten ich noch nicht und
vielleicht denken wir alle mal an den
lokalen handel vor ort und nicht den
online riesen um die ecke und besorgen
da vielleicht noch mal noch mal rein
herzlichen dank und gemeinsam kommen wir
da wieder raus
sagt andrea huberts für die spd-fraktion
hier in ihrer ersten rede
[Applaus]
das wort hat der abgeordnete dr michael
espendiller für die aus tv zu
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen liebe zuschauer im
saal und bei youtube und ganz besonders
liebe genossen von der fdp stehen sie
sich vor ihre familie hat ihn nach 80
oder 100 jahren existenz die
verantwortung für das
familienunternehmen anvertraut und jetzt
müssen sie hilflos zuschauen wie dieses
unternehmens stirbt es stirbt weil eine
regierung nach der anderen in die
lebensgrundlage entzieht und das ist
keine fiktion der deutsche mittelstand
ist in auflösung begriffen
traditionsreiche firmen müssen dicht
machen und sich von verdienten und
langjährigen mitarbeitern trennen und
die staatlichen kroner maßnahmen wirken
dabei wie ein booster für diese
zerstörerische entwicklung leider wird
auch die neue ampel regierung diesen
prozess eher beschleunigen als bremse
zwar geht es in diesem hier vorgelegten
gesetzesentwurf um die verlängerung von
wirtschaftlichen
stabilisierungsmaßnahmen die sonst zum
jahresende ausgelaufen wäre doch diese
instrumente sind zu bürokratisch und
helfen zuvor das den großen und eben
nicht dem rückgrat unserer wirtschaft
dem deutschen mittelstand
[Applaus]
sie vergessen bei der verteilung ihrer
milden gaben nämlich all jene kleinen
und mittleren unternehmen die im letzten
existenzkampf gar nicht mehr die kraft
haben sich mit ihrer bürokratie
herumzuschlagen und genau jetzt zur
selben zeit trudeln bei den
mittelständlern die
rückforderungsbescheide zu corona hilfen
aus dem ersten lok tor und im märz 2020
ein der verband der gründer und
selbstständigen deutschland befürchtet
dass das für viele betriebe der
todesstoß sein wird und dagegen wehrte
kollegen unternehmen sie leider nichts
und das ist verantwortungslos
es passt aber leider auch zu einer
politik die die lebenswirklichkeit der
unternehmer nicht mehr kennt und nicht
mehr versteht der mittelstand ist der
hauptarbeitgeber in deutschland ist er
besteht aus 40 millionen menschen die
zum selbständigen und angestellten
mittelstand gehören und diese menschen
dürfen wir nicht vergessen in der korona
maßnahmen zeit haben wir bereits mehr
als
300.000 selbstständige verloren ihre
zahl ist damit auf rund 3,9 millionen
gefallen das ist der tiefste stand seit
25 jahren und das ist ein riesiger
struktureller und innovativer aderlass
der uns alle alarmieren muss hier in
diesem hohen haus haben die aufgabe auch
an die kleinen und mittelständischen
unternehmen zu denken und da diese von
dem hier vorgelegten gesetzesentwurf
leider nur mangelhaft profitieren können
wir uns leider auch nur enthalten
wenngleich wie ihr bemühen um die
sicherstellung der liquidität von firmen
zum erhalt größere strukturen durchaus
anerkennen deshalb lehnen wir den
gesetzesentwurf auch nicht ab denn die
afc will die deutsche wirtschaft
unterstützen aber wir wenden uns
ausdrücklich gegen den umbau unserer
wirtschafts und gesellschaftsordnung
zulasten des mittelstands und zu lasten
unserer bürgerlichen freiheiten die
appellieren daher an sie werte kollegen
der ampel haben sie auch endlich mein
herz für die kleinen selbstständigen in
deutschland
[Applaus]
michael müller war das für die afg
fraktion hier zur zweiten lesung
wirtschaftsstabilisierung
beschleunigungsgesetz heißt das ganze
technisch betrachtet und dazu hören wir
jetzt nochmal eine erste rede hier und
es war diesmal aus dem rheiner grünen
und das wird sein jamila schäfer
wies jetzt mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
damen und herren wir schütten uns immer
noch mitten in einer pandemie kliniken
pflegerinnen und pfleger ärzte und ärzte
sind am rande ihrer belastungsgrenze
oder schon weiter hinaus und wir sind es
ihnen schuldig dass wir konsequent
maßnahmen ergreift um diese pandemie zu
bekämpfen ich bin froh sagen zu können
alle demokratischen parteien dieses
hauses sind sich darüber einig und das
ist wichtig denn wir müssen
zusammenstehen gegen die ideologen von
rechtsaußen die die ängste der menschen
für ihren machterhalt
instrumentalisieren das ist ein sch
ewigkeit oder mensch menschenverachtung
nicht zu überbieten
angesichts gefährlicher virus varianten
und einer viel zu niedrige impfquote und
der lage auf den intensivstationen sind
wir weiterhin zu kontakt beschränkungen
verpflichtet veranstaltungen müssen
abgesagt werden und wir müssen massiv in
den alltag der menschen eingreifen wir
wissen dass diese notwendigen
beschränkungen für viele branchen und
betriebe sehr negative teils sehr
tragische auswirkungen haben viele
unternehmen sind unverschuldet in not
geraten wichtige wirtschaftszweige wie
zum beispiel die veranstaltungsbranche
die tourismusbranche oder die
transportbranche und die gastronomie
sind ganz besonders hart getroffen viele
unternehmen kann nicht mehr vernünftig
wirtschaften was heißt das ja das heißt
dass viele menschen da draußen angst
haben gerade ihren job zu verlieren
das heißt dass viele eltern angst davor
haben ihre kinder nicht mehr ordentlich
versorgen zu können dass auszubildende
ihre stelle verlieren und damit
natürlich auch ihre berufliche zukunft
das sind die echten menschlichen
schicksale die hinter so abstrakten
begriffen wie einer abflauenden
konjunktur städte und für die vielen
kleinen betriebe die durch die
notwendigen kontakt beschränkung
straucheln haben wir die
unternehmenshilfen auf den weg gebracht
und das ist gut so aber wir brauchen
auch hilfen und instrumente für größere
unternehmen denn auch sie sich an
zahllose arbeitsplätze und leisten einen
großen beitrag zur stabilität der
wirtschaft die gesichert werden muss
[Applaus]
wir dürfen deshalb nicht zulassen dass
die erfolgreichen stabilisierenden
maßnahmen mitten in der pandemie
auslaufen solange es die gravierenden
einschränkungen gibt die unsere
unternehmen aber auch arbeitsplätze und
einkommen gefährden brauchen wir sie und
heute können wir gemeinsam dafür sorgen
dass die handlungsfähigkeit unseres
wirtschafts- stabilisierungsfonds auch
nach dem 31 dezember 20 21 doch
sichergestellt wir müssen dieser
verantwortung heute gerecht werden und
daher plädieren dafür die verlängerung
ist wirtschaft stabilisierungsfonds bis
mitte des nächsten jahres zuzustimmen
[Applaus]
aber das möchte ich auch ganz deutlich
sagen es kann nicht sein dass die
allgemeinheit für wirtschaftliche
risiken aufkommt und das ohne
gegenleistung
die vermögen von und von privaten
eigentümern gerettet werden es ist nicht
zu viel gesagt und verlangt dass bei den
unternehmen die sich unter den
schutzschirm stellen auch die
eigentümerseite zur rettung beiträgt und
daher dient die verlängerung des
wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds auch
der stabilisierung der wirtschaft und
nicht der stabilisierung von manager
boni
wir werden alles dafür tun dass wir im
haushaltsausschuss sicherstellen dass
auch kein steuergeld für dividenden
zahlungen an aktionäre geben wird das
geld muss da landen wo möglichst viele
menschen profitieren und nicht nur
einige wenige
[Applaus]
ja wir reden gerade über die stabilität
unserer arbeitsplätze unserer einkommen
und unserer wirtschaft und deshalb ist
es eben nicht egal wofür diese gelder
ausgegeben werden denn die stabilität
unseres wirtschaftens gehört nicht nur
die rettung von unternehmen und jobs
sondern auch die rettung unserer
ökosysteme und darum muss klar sein wer
sich unter unseren rettungsschirm stellt
der muss sich auch mit uns gemeinsam auf
den pfad der klimaneutralität begeben
denn es gibt keinen wohlstand ohne den
schutz unserer lebensgrundlagen
vielen dank
das wort hat die kollegin dr gesine
lötzsch für die fraktion die linke
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren die neue koalition
nennt sich nun fortschritts koalition
und darum prüfen wir jedes gesetz auf
diesem anspruch auch gerecht wird und
ich sage was dieses gesetz betrifft es
ist kein fortschritt meine damen und
herren ja wir haben ja wir haben im märz
2020 dem wirtschaft stabilisierungsfonds
zugestimmt was waren unsere gründe wir
wollten möglichst viele arbeitsplätze
retten doch dem gesetz und das habe ich
auch in der rede damals gesagt hielten
damals schon klare soziale und
ökologische regelung und die vermissen
wir auch in den neuen gesetz und das
kann ich gehen meine damen und herren
die lufthansa das ist schon erwähnt
worden von der fdp wurde mit
steuergeldern gerettet aber das
management hat daraufhin tausende
beschäftigte entlassen und die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die
bleiben durften mussten kräftige geld
einbußen hinnehmen und auf der anderen
seite war das management nicht bereit
die öffentlichkeit über ihre aktivitäten
in steueroasen zu unterrichten das ist
nicht hinzunehmen das passt nicht
zusammen meine damen und herren
und wenn wir die kp erwähnt worden ist
wenn ich doch mal der öffentlichkeit
sagen dass in der café sehr sehr viele
also der kreditanstalt für wiederaufbau
oder staatliche förderbank sehr viel
geld bewegt wird im jahr 2020 zum
beispiel waren es 135 milliarden
förderung aber im verwaltungsrat der kfw
sind nicht alle parteien vertreten und
das ist demokratischen china bei den
damen und herren
großen hat uns leicht an diese
fördergelder zu kommen und ich bin immer
wieder entsetzt mit welcher
bürokratische aufwand kleine und
mittlere unternehmen zugeschüttet werden
und wie bedingungslos konzerne
milliarden von steuergeldern bekommen
das darf so nicht weitergehen meint
ankam
fortschritt muss heißen klare soziale
und ökologische vorgaben doch diesen
fortschritt kann ich in diesem gesetz
leider nicht erkennen meine damen und
herren es ist zeit für mehr solidarität
es ist zeit dass die vermögen in ihren
beitrag leisten es ist zeit für eine
vermögensabgabe herzlichen dank
wir sind zwar das von der linken und die
vermögensabgabe hatte sie heute schon
mal in einer rede angeführt nämlich
heute morgen als es um den zweiten
nachtragshaushalt ging
was ganz neues werden wir jetzt hören
denn es ist ihre erste rede von kathrin
michel für die sozialdemokraten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
tschetschenien jack nasher
wirtschaftsstabilisierung
beschleunigungsgesetz zugegebenermaßen
davon habe ich geträumt als ich dachte
worüber ich meine erste rede halten
werde im bundestag doch der inhalt des
gesetzes ist klar und deutlich es geht
im kern dieser debatte um nichts weniger
als eine krisenbedingt notwendige
stabilisierung unserer heimischen
wirtschaft die stabilisierung von
unternehmen die von den auswirkungen der
anhaltenden cupid 19 pandemie
existenziell betroffen sind und nicht
zuletzt auch um den schutz von
arbeitsplätzen
derjenigen menschen die tag für tag ihre
arbeit leisten und damit unsere
wirtschaftskraft prägen die zu recht in
der ganzen welt anerkennung findet
corinna steht uns weiterhin vor immense
herausforderungen
viele medizinische fachkräfte kämpfen
täglich weit über ihre kräfte hinaus um
das leben von patientinnen und patienten
die auf intensivstation behandelt werden
müssen dass wir den gesundheitsbereich
schnellstmöglich und nachhaltig
entlasten und die angemessene versorgung
von menschen gewährleisten die schwer
krank oder verletzt sind oder sich einer
notwendigen operation unterziehen müssen
hat höchste priorität
so fleißig die partie auch auf weitere
bereiche aus die wir im zuge der
krisenbewältigung nicht außer acht
lassen dürfen unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer erleben in anbetracht der
europa- und weltweit
gesamtwirtschaftlichen lage auch
weiterhin eine ökonomische unsicherheit
die wir als gesetzgeber und
gesetzgeberische etwas entgegensetzen
müssen wir wollen und müssen das
vertrauen in die reaktions und
handlungsfähigkeit des staates
angesichts der anhaltenden corona krise
stärken ja wir haben die pflicht lösung
auch für diese bestehende ökonomische
unsicherheit zu bieten
aus diesem grund stellen wir die
handlungsfähigkeit des wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds auch über den 31
dezember 2021 hinaus sicher die in
unserem gesetzentwurf vorgesehene
verlängerung der befristungsregeln im
stabilisierungsfonds gesetz schafft die
notwendige gesetzliche grundlage zur
gewährung der stabilisierungsmaßnahmen
durch den wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds für ein weiteres
halbes jahr bis zum 30 26 22 wir führen
in diesem zusammenhang eine antragsfrist
bis zum 30 april 2022 ein um eben
unternehmen im speziellen bedarfsfall im
besagten zeitraum die entsprechenden
hilfen gewähren zu können mit dem
vorgelegten gesetzesentwurf
gewährleisten wir dass herten der
pandemie abgemildert werden und
betroffene unternehmen die sicherheit
geboten wird die sie auch in den
kommenden monaten dringend benötigen
werden
im zelt entsteht die solvenz der
unternehmen zu erhalten arbeitsplätze
können gesichert werden und somit
entfaltet das gesetz auch die nötige
arbeitsmarktpolitische wirkung der
wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds wurde
bereits 2020 eingerichtet und auch ich
habe hier das beispiel der deutschen
lufthansa ag auf dem zettel die stillen
rücklagen des bundes konnten vorzeitig
zurückgezahlt werden und das zeigt eben
sehr deutlich dass es hier diskutierte
instrument wird es bietet die
entscheidende brücke die entscheidende
brücke
unternehmen um aus der finanziellen
hilfsbedürftigkeit rasch zur
unternehmerischen selbstständigkeit
zurück zu finden es stabilisiert unsere
wirtschaft wie auch den arbeitsmarkt
nachhaltig und zugleich ist die
belastung der öffentlichen haushalte bei
anwendung dieser maßnahme begrenzt auch
durch die im fond vorgesehene
möglichkeit staatliche beteiligung an
unternehmen zu erwerben und garantie
prämien zu erheben in diesem
zusammenhang ziehen ihre zitiere ich
abschließend unseren bundeskanzler olaf
scholz kluge politik zahlt sich aus und
kluge politik zahlt sich in der tat aus
sie zahlt sich aus für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
sie zahlt sich aus für die stärkung
unserer wirtschaftskraft und es zeigt
sich deutlich dass das gesetz genau den
rahmen bietet den wir brauchen um
weiterhin gemeinsam die krise zu
bewältigen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen lassen
sie es uns gemeinsam angehen denn nur so
werden wir erfolg haben vielen dank und
glückauf
hab mich hier mit ihrer ersten rede
sie ist über die landesliste sachsen
übrigens in den bundestag eingezogen und
kommt aus der lausitz sebastian brehm
letzter redner hier zu diesem
tagesordnungspunkt für die
unionsfraktion frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mit
dem vorliegenden gesetz sollen die
korona hilfen für unternehmen und die
stabilisierungsmaßnahmen bis 30.06
2022 verlängert werden das ist notwendig
angesichts der weiter anhaltenden
pandemie wir werden insbesondere unsere
mittelständler in deutschland hier nicht
im regen stehen lassen
das ist selbstverständlich auch übrigens
in unserer neuen rolle auch zur
opposition deshalb stimmen wir heute
diesen gesetz auch zu
immerhin
es ist eine verlängerung eines von der
cdu/csu initiiert und eingeführten
wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds
corona bedingte stabilisierungsmaßnahmen
waren zunächst bis 31 12 21 begrenzt und
werden nun richtigerweise bis 30.06
2022 verlängert soweit alles okay aber
es sind drei dinge die mir große sorgen
machen erstens
die beantragung der hilfen wird nur bis
zum 30 vierter genehmigt keine
fristverlängerung obwohl das programm
bis 30.6 2022 läuft das ist uns
systematisch liebe kollegen und kollegen
handwerklich übrigens falsch und zeugt
davon dass sie nicht aus der praxis
kommen und wissen welche belastungen
hier auf den mittelstand zu kommen
insbesondere weil auch im ersten quartal
2022 die schlussrechnungen für 20 und 21
vorgenommen werden müssen zweitens
das haben sie im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart sie wollen die
schuldentilgung von 20 jahren um weitere
16 jahre auf 36 jahre verlängern und sie
sprechen von nachhaltiger
haushaltspolitik das ist keine
nachhaltige haushaltspolitik sondern
belastet die nächsten generationen
maßgeblich und drittens
und drittens und das macht mir die
allergrößten sorgen niemand weiß wie die
ampelkoalition dieses finanzieren will
es liegt kein finanztableau vor die fdp
hätte übrigens damals in ihrer damaligen
rolle das nie durchgehen lassen und
sofort kritisiert heute ist der
finanzminister von der fdp und legt ein
finanztableau vor also er macht eine
intransparente
haushaltspolitik und er habe ich wurde
gefragt im zdf von hat gesagt ja es gebe
wohl eine finanzplanung aber in der tat
hätte man die vielleicht offenlegen
müssen gleichwohl keine offenlegung um
kein finanztableau und ihre kolleginnen
und kollegen wer keine offenlegung und
keine transparente haushaltspolitik
macht der hat was zu verschweigen oder
steht zumindest im verdacht was zu
verschweigen zu wollen und deswegen
frage ich mich warum
und die frage ist ganz einfach sie
wollen offiziell und offensichtlich
die mit der nichtvorlage der
finanzplanung die umgehung der
schuldenbremse machen der kollege der
hat gesagt in der diskussion im
bundestag es gibt keine neuverschuldung
in der tat gibt es eine neuverschuldung
von 60 milliarden euro das ist die
wahrheit und das müssen sie auch in der
debatte sagen und was noch viel
schlimmer ist was noch viel schlimmer
ist es gibt sie ändern die buchungs
regeln für diese sondervermögen
vereinfacht heißt es für die bürgerinnen
und bürger das geld kann von in diesem
sondervermögen ohne beteiligung des
haushaltsausschusses für alles andere
verwendet werden außer für die korona
maßnahmen zu bunkern damit geld im
haushalt für wahlgeschenke
2023 2024
wenn ausgaben gemacht werden muss der
haushaltsausschuss hier beteiligt werden
das ist eine umgehung aus meiner sicht
des haushaltsrechts des deutschen
bundestages und es werden medial richter
ich gehen lassen das nicht
verfassungsrechtlich geklärt werden
gestatten sie eine frage oder
selbstverständlich dem legen fricke
jawohl otto fricke fragt für die fdp
fraktion als regierungspolitiker immer
als ein fachlich ausdifferenzierter
kollege
doch wirklich klar geworden und das fand
ich auch immer sehr gut selbst wenn man
unterschiedlicher meinung ist deswegen
würde ich sie gerne darauf hinweisen
dass die ersten von zwei völlig
verschiedenen dingen reden sie bewusst
durcheinanderbringen erster das was sie
bei diesem gesetzentwurf hier kritisiert
haben die fragen wer auseinandergehen
der antrags- pflicht und die frage bis
wann der fonds noch arbeitet darf ich
darauf hinweisen dass wenn die cdu
wünscht die antragsfrist bis ende juni
weiter fortzusetzen dann müssten anträge
die im ende juni eingehen noch im juli
bearbeitet werden und dann werden sie
uns ende juni sagen wir müssen aber den
vorn noch weiter verlängern denn sie
müssen bearbeitet drittens
drittens herr kollege bremen könnten sie
mir sagen welchen änderungsantrag dieser
art die cdu gestellt hat im ausschuss
oder hier im plenum um dieses angeblich
zu verhindern viertens neue schulden
werden nicht gemacht die
kreditermächtigungen bleibt auf dem
niveau wo sie ist im haushalt hier
streichen wir kreditermächtigung von 50
milliarden und darüber hätten sie reden
können
[Musik]
herzlichen dank ist sie verlängern damit
ihr auch meine redezeit um nochmal zu
erläutern also vielen dank bisher war es
immer so dass die
antragsfristen auch gleich lauten waren
mit der frist sozusagen oder mit dem
lauf des programms und das genau und das
kürzen sie jetzt bewusst um die
unternehmer noch mehr unter druck zu
setzen und diejenigen die die anträge
bearbeiten müssen damit nein eben nicht
wenn sie sie haben es doch verkürzt
erster erster bis 30 vierter ist kürzer
als erster erster bis 30.6 dies ergibt
sich daraus der mathematik schon alleine
also insofern da haben sie glaube ich
werden sie nachbessern müssen es wird im
frühjahr dazu kommen mit den
schlussabrechnung mit dieser großen
belastung des mittelstands dass sie die
fristen verlängern müssen um nicht das
programm zu verlängern aber die
beantragung fristen müssen sie
verlängern übrigens je mehr sie oder je
mehr sieht die antragsfrist verkürzen
desto mehr schätzungen wird es geben
weil man natürlich dass auf den fünften
und sechsten monat schätzen muss dh
desto mehr unsicherheit gibt es im
deutschen mittelstand auch bei der
schlussabrechnung und rückzahlungen als
er sie gehen das bewusstein wir haben
das diskutiert werden das auch
angesprochen in der ersten lesung aber
sie wollten ja nicht hier eine änderung
vornehmen also letztlich macht auch gar
keinen sinn jetzt ein anderer zu stellen
weiß dass sie es ablehnen also wenn wenn
müssen sie schon einfach mit aufnehmen
aber sie werden es machen müssen sie
werden es machen müssen das wird sich im
verlauf der zeit im frühjahr ergeben und
zweitens sie nehmen sehr wohl 60
milliarden neue schulden auf und sie
ändern sehr wohl die buchungs regelung
für diese sondervermögen also das können
sie nicht bestreiten und es liegt auch
kein finanztableau vor das können sie
nicht bestreiten also haben sie in
transparente hauspolitik
haushaltspolitik sie zeigen uns nicht
auf wie sie das letztendlich finanzieren
und sie geben auch nicht in den
haushaltsausschuss wenn hier mittel noch
frei bleiben wie die dann ausgegeben
werden das ist doch der vorwurf sie
hätten sie wenn sie in der damaligen
rolle gewesen wären niemals
durchgelassen reden von kollegen dürre
die reden von ihnen die reden von der
gesamten fdp vormann kollege lindner die
hätte ich eins zu eins heute halten
können sie haben innerhalb von fünf
tagen eine komplette kehrtwendung ihre
finanzpolitischen haushaltspolitischen
grundsätze gemacht das ist die wahrheit
und das muss man an seinen solchen tag
auch mal leider sagen können
also summa summarum die verlängerung
wird kommen müssen aus praktischen
gründen man wird aber auch diese
haushalt praktik und diese intransparenz
letztlich auch in karlsruhe prüfen
müssen und dann bin ich gespannt was
dabei rauskommt ich denke dass sie hier
nachbessern werden müssen so lassen wir
ihnen das nicht durchgehen herzlichen
dank
das jahren war das für die cdu csu
fraktion allerdings jetzt zu diesem hier
vorliegende gesetz auf hatte die cdu csu
fraktion zur zustimmung signalisiert und
fdp eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur
änderung des stabilisierungs-gesetzes
und das wirtschafts stabilisierungs
beschleunigungsgesetz der hauptausschuss
empfiehlt in seiner beschlussempfehlung
auf drucksache
246 den gesetzentwurf der fraktionen der
spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp auf
drucksache
189 anzugeben ich bitte diejenigen die
dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen um
das handzeichen
das sind die koalitionsfraktionen und
die cdu csu fraktion bestimmt dagegen
niemand mehr enthält sich das sind die
fraktionen der fdp und die linke der
gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
beratung angenommen dritte beratung und
schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
danke
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
danke der gesetzentwurf ist mit den
stimmen der spd fraktion der fdp
fraktion der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen und der cdu csu fraktion bei
enthaltung der fraktion raf die und die
linke angenommen ich rufe es hatte sich
ja in der debatte schon angedeutet dass
mit den ampel-koalition ehren hier die
cdu/csu-fraktion eben zustimmen dass
dieser corona hilfen um ein halbes jahr
verlängert werden auch wenn das gut um
insgesamt
verringert wird